will you guys hit some headlines with us
let's do it all right why not okay
all right
what is it well you know when it comes
to dating things are looking up for the
little guys the new york post reports
short men are having a renaissance in
fact tick tock says we're smack in the
middle of something called short king
spring
so if you're a cutie if you're a cutie
below five eight i'm talking to you
yeah short king spring could turn into
short king summer and look people are
checking out hot guys like tom holland
and zendaya look at them taller than
yeah
uh joe jonas and sophie turner yeah
yeah
and um
listen i'm all for short kings frank i
was pushing peewee winter for a while
but
to be under five eight i'm five seven
i'm getting close but i'm glad it's
slowly the time is turning
and a lot of there's a lot of
misreporting on the height
the heights of of actors i mean i don't
want to give anything away but this is
it's it's an illusion film chris
hemsworth five foot six honest to god
bradley cooper bradley cooper five two
channing tatum 4 11. you heard it here
so this is tom cruise is 5 1.
you guys did your research yeah
yeah right and tall beautiful people can
sometimes not be too swift on the uptake
not real bright
david and i are the exception but my
point is this no go ahead drew short
shaming it's got to go away because you
can't you can't help it if someone's
they say fat shaming is bad and maybe
you could have something to do with that
sure you're just short if i could eat a
lot and be taller i would so
um
it's not going to happen well also i'm
sure it's probably deceptive for a lot
of people what do you mean just saying
what are you talking about i don't know
i'm just saying you mean nature nature
has a way of balancing gifts out
yeah yeah
our mind is in the gutter
yes she is church lady yes she is i'm a
bad girl
but you are and i want to thank you
anyway uh i like kagita good speaking
next step all right next story all right
we've got a dilemma that we found on
reddit i thought this was actually
really interesting this was discussed on
elvis duran's morning show who i love
hey elvis if you're out there um what do
you do if your sister is planning to
name your future nephew their child
after an actual crime one woman wrote
that she's feuding with her sister after
criticizing her name choice of arson
which is a ripoff of fire starter fire
starter yes
uh hello know uh my son's name is poison
pete but that's a whole other story um
my kid my kid harper goes to school but
the real names are like yale
captain like real interesting names that
i never had so those are kind of just
cool and different but when it gets into
crimes i don't love it as much maybe i i
draw the line i mean i had a switch
hitter name that always traumatized me
dana you know i got put in girls p not a
joke in in high school names are funny
david has a regular name i've got kind
of a switch hitter name and drew is a
switch hitter now i was gonna say i i i
have a boy girl name i'm into the
androgynous though so you know i just
think there should be a rule just
because it's a pretty word doesn't make
it a good name like you don't want to be
hey grand larceny come home come on you
catch that because you know what else is
a pretty pretty word yeah car crash yeah
i know what else is a pretty word
chlamydia is a pretty word
beautiful word not a great name
and not a great thing no gonorrhea eat
your cereal
really i like napalm i like the captain
david that's a good name for like this
is kind of a cool one yeah it's hard to
fix i like these there's some
interesting names
well i'm the captain now because i have
the next story all right
another conundrum
styles it has an advice column and a
woman wrote in to say it bothers her
that her boyfriend likes bikini photos
of other women on instagram
not famous bikini models but you know
just everyday women who are posing in
bikinis online that he actually knows
he's liking their photos so here's oh he
knows even worse yeah right
yeah so isn't it i mean is it okay is it
okay uh i'll take this first dana um i
think if you have a girlfriend or wife
it is rude and those likes are to get
attention it's like morse code like like
like like
like you're just trying to communicate
and you want them to
maybe uh notice you and that's that's a
tough that's a tough one to defend i
would say
[Music]